the leaders of u.s and china stressed
their shared responsibility to avoid
conflict in their first ever virtual
summit u.s president joe biden and
chinese president xi jinping held the
video call at a time of worsening
relations between the superpowers
there's no shortage of tension over
issues like taiwan and human rights
flashpoints in a rivalry that dominates
the global stage
as three hours of virtual meetings
wrapped up the leaders of the u.s and
china could agree on one thing
get out of each other's way
the two nations stressed the need for
their competition to remain peaceful
as i've said before it seems to me our
responsibility as leaders of china and
the united states
to ensure that the competition between
our countries
does not veer into conflict whether
intended or unintended just simple
straightforward competition
chinese president xi jinping says
cooperation benefits not only the us and
china but also the world
[Music]
right now both china and the united
states are at critical stages of
development and humanity lives in a
global village and we face multiple
challenges together
as the world's two largest economies and
permanent members of the un security
council china and the u.s need to
increase communication and cooperation
it was a public attempt at lowering the
temperatures between the two superpowers
amid rising tensions
but in private disagreements were raised
in the meeting policy towards taiwan
continued to separate the two with xi
saying any u.s interference is like
playing with fire
beijing claims that the self-governing
island is part of china while the u.s
has vowed to protect taiwanese
independence
biden raised china's human rights record
in hong kong tibet and xinjiang
also expressing their concern at china's
buildup of nuclear weapons
but china was quick to point out that
their stockpile
is much smaller than the one in the
united states
no agreements or announcements are
expected to come from this summit but
the two leaders welcomed the opportunity
for frank conversations
for more i'm joined by dw correspondent
uh washington correspondent oliver salad
and beijing based journalist fabian
kreshma oliver let's start with you
biden initiated this virtual meeting to
help defuse tensions now did he get what
he was hoping for
well tell me he did certainly not go
into these consultations with big
expectations with regards to the outcome
so what he wanted to do here is to
revive some good old diplomacy if you
will knowing that this is probably the
best way to avoid confrontation of the
two countries
actually this virtual summit this
virtual meeting was considered the first
formal meeting between the two
presidents if you take out some phone
calls that were made
throughout the year they have never met
in person since president biden took
office and that's almost one year ago so
we have the two biggest economies at the
table here
with military active in the same region
so certainly a long overdue conversation
fabian let's come to you now xi jinping
called for more communication and
cooperation uh between the two sides do
you see any scope for that
well if you listen closely then um xi
jinping even
called joe biden an old friend and of
course this is just symbolic
rhetoric but it is meaningful because we
come from really the worst bilateral
relations of the two countries in
more than three decades and um so it
shows really a genuine attempt that
china is hoping for a restart of
bilateral relations and xi jinping
singled out basically two fields for
cooperation and one is the global
climate change and the other one is
the
pandemic and those probably are the two
fields where there's the biggest overlap
of interest
between these two countries and probably
the only fields where we can see
immediate cooperation
uh these so-called old friends oliver uh
the u.s and china are at odds over many
issues which one do you think was the
thorniest in this meeting
well first of all these this meeting was
held behind closed doors there were no
cameras and only a few statements have
been made public until now what we heard
from the white house just a little while
ago is that president biden apparently
was critical of unfair trade practices
is certainly a an old story that we've
heard under the trump administration and
even before
many many times the future of taiwan was
tackled with the u.s commitment of
course
and then human rights abuses tibet hong
kong xinjiang another topic that could
have been on the agenda is cyber
security so the list is really long as
you can see and there are really few
areas of common ground one exception is
climate change and we also heard of
chinese state media that china
reportedly vowed to open its economy
further for u.s companies that would
certainly be
a substantial outcome and an achievement
for the biden administration
uh fabian uh realistically when it comes
to these issues and oliver has mentioned
uh quite a list of them
is china really open for
compromise well on the economic issues
yes but um the core issues um
let's say taiwan and also the human
rights violations
we know for sure that um
china under xi jinping will not move an
inch from their position
um i know that clearly because when i'm
in in exchange with the diplomats here
um
they tell me that you know back in the
days before shooting ping they would at
least listen to our critique but now um
it basically there's no exchange anymore
there's not even a con consensus on on
the factual um foundation of those
issues for example in xinjiang i mean
basically the government here does not
acknowledge the the camps at all they
call them re-education uh training
centers etc and also they call very
openly for unification with taiwan um i
don't see um to be honest any compromise
it's simply not possible so um
we are hopeful that at least the tone is
getting better and more friendly but in
the future those conflicts will remain
and will not disappear at all
okay fabian kashmir in beijing and
oliver sallet in washington
many thanks to you both
you